wir werden den krieg nicht nicht
nachzulassen
wo kann man heutzutage besser
rekrutieren als auf einer friedensdemo
wir brauchen kampf wege unverbrauchte
nachwuchskräfte wehrdienst gestern noch
verpönt auf einmal der heiße scheiß und
vor allem brauchen wir junge leute die
ein gezogen wir auch nicht die alten
müssen in den kriegsjahren wenn es drauf
ankommt als reservisten sehen und die
jungen leuten dabei die playstation
soundso was die bundeswehr wir auch
früher für unsere männer für unsere
jungs nie verkehrt
haben der spinnt aufzuräumen und auf zum
rahmen gelernt zu saufen wir haben
gelernt lkw zu fahren das war auch ein
ausweichen
es hat keinem geschadet
was mit ihnen zum beispiel haben sie
einen lkw führerschein
ja das ist dann natürlich dass da gegen
polen
sag mir wo die blumen sind jetzt ist
wieder helmpflicht angesagt endlich kann
man sich wieder spüren die bundeswehr
ist wieder wer zumindest für die meisten
eine reihe von der bundeswehr
warum gehst du nicht zur bundeswehr
tatsächlich hat sich inzwischen so
ich habe jeden fall fragen für dich
schnell musterung hinzu es reicht für
liechtenstein frankreich russland oder
mein mindestanspruch an fitness ich kann
sehr schnell rennen mit schnellen kann
ich mich nicht richtung steuern die alte
natürlich ja darf ich dir mal an die
hoden fassen so wie heißt die aktuelle
bundesverteidigungsministerium landrecht
mitwirken von haben ist es den rand
recht hast du ganz schlauer bisher also
ich verstehe also im dienst nichts für
das feld dann natürlich eine ganz
wichtige sache und für mich eigentlich
der schützen erinnerung an die musterung
darf ich dir mal an den boden fasst ich
bin schwul
das heißt ja oder nein ach so
gut es gibt immer noch nachwuchsprobleme
deshalb will ich mich dort eher
tüchtigen dort wo es wehtut bei zwei
echten bundeswehr nahkampf ausbilder
ausbildern in der regel würden wir die
ausbilder im nahkampf aus die bundeswehr
krieg doch eigentlich genug kohle
demnächst sogar noch 100 milliarden und
ob warum braucht man externe die einzige
im voraus bild das kann ich auch selber
machen in unserem schönen steuergeld
ach ja in den 80ern beim zivildienst da
hatte ich noch einen sanfteren blick auf
die welt aber heute
papier
stammt der ganzen fuß in das
kann so ein soldat in einer
grundausbildung kann der überhaupt wert
was wert sein für die bundeswehr oder
ist er eher hinderlich nein also ich
glaube dass er auf jeden fall was wert
sein kann und die bundeswehr hat zeit
der umwandlungen die berufsarmee die ich
glaube ich für richtig halte
aber nachwuchsproblem und das ist immer
noch nicht ganz so im griff und ich
glaube da wird auch kein geld helfen
aber die sind aus meiner sicht extrem
wichtig weil im moment machen die gut
ausgebildeten soldaten teilweise
aufgaben die auch jemand anderes
übernehmen könnte ja
es sind merkwürdige zeit in zeiten wo es
wenige antworten gibt aber ganz viele
fragen aber
[Gelächter]
aber ich stehe doch wieder an eine
bundeswehr war
aber ich stehe dafür dass der putin
nicht angreift was haben die 16
unterricht aus
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher